yeah I wonder your relationship your
marriage with Steve so public and out in
the open and many people felt like we
you know we kind of knew you guys and I
wondered if on any level that aspect the
fact that so many people sort of
associate me the state if that has made
it more difficult or difficult to get
out there and date again
oh it's really nothing that I'm
considering I think I've had my happily
ever after and I still heal immense love
and loyalty to Steve and I've got great
kids I've got a very full life and while
I'm lonely for Steve I'm not a lonely
person so I'm doing okay but I think if
I hadn't met Steve I probably would've
never married so that's that's how
unique our relationship was and I think
for other people who have lost someone
and loved again it's a beautiful thing
but it's just not my horizon so I'm okay
I'm lonely for Steve but I'm not a
little person I think it's a beautiful
thing you make that distinction thank
you various no worries at all and that's
you know that's kind of what how we go
through life is if we can talk about
what we've experienced and it can help
other people it's worth talking about so
it was like the boobs beautiful dance
with Derrick commemorating her dad I
think that was so special because she
was bringing everyone's grief journey
with with her on her journey and saying
you can lose someone and then find joy
you